hi there and thanks so much for clicking
on this video my name is bradley knapp
and i'm with ibm cloud and the topic
we're going to discuss today is what is
an rca or a root cause analysis
all right so to start off with an rca is
a standard process that you should go
through any time within the technology
industry that you have what i like to
call a customer impacting event or a
serious event where something has gone
wrong and it has resulted in serious
problems for your customers it could be
a downtime outage it could be a loss of
network connectivity it could be a loss
of electricity but no matter what the
problem is this rca process which is
seven steps
that this rca process is designed to
help you not only identify what the
problem is but how to fix it so that it
doesn't ever happen again so
with that in mind let's jump right in
right so the first step in rca and i
know this seems basic but it is the
first and most important step is you
must
identify
what went wrong right you have to
identify your problem and that means you
have to define your problem it's not
just a matter of figuring out the
symptoms the symptom is my computing
environment stopped being available or
the database dropped offline that's a
symptom that's not identifying what the
problem is
the first step in that rca is figure out
what it is that went wrong and so in
order to identify what went wrong your
second step which is really related to
the first is you must collect
data
because the decisions that you are going
to make as part of this rca process
have to be based in data they can't be
based in guess they can't be yes based
in
conjecture you have to know
what went wrong and you have to have the
data to back that up sometimes you get a
little glitch that results itself
automatically you're still going to want
to run an rca process on that and you
want to know what caused the glitch you
can't just trust that it's going to
magically fix itself in the future so
you must collect data now next step
is you have identified your problem
right you've defined it you've got your
data you now have to ask
why and asking why is more than just
asking the question you have to make
causal connections
so
as we're asking why
we have to get really in-depth right it
can't just be
all right well the power went out and as
a result these breakers tripped and then
when the power came back on the breakers
didn't automatically reset you have to
know why didn't they automatically reset
is it because you weren't doing your
preventative maintenance correctly or
you were doing your preventative
maintenance correctly but the schedule
wasn't right or even though you were
doing the preventative maintenance and
the schedule was right maybe the
equipment just failed did it fail in
service did it fail out of service do
you need to go back to the manufacturer
of that equipment and find out what on
earth is going on because things did not
happen the way that they should have you
have to ask why and you have to make
those causal connections and remember
one of the biggest goals of the rca is
to not only figure out what you did in
order to solve the problem you have to
figure out how to keep from keep it from
happening again if you don't get to that
point there's no point in doing an rca
it's just a paperwork exercise why even
bother with it
so we've identified what went wrong
we've got our data we've asked why we've
made those causal connections between
everything that went wrong to figure out
what happened because remember in the
world of technology our problems are
very very rarely a single thing it is
almost always a cascading error of some
kind that started with something simple
and cascaded into something serious so
we've made those causal connections
now we have to actually figure out what
are we going to fix right we are going
to identify
those corrections
so
we've identified what it is that we're
going to fix and solving it
isn't just a matter of figuring out what
it is you're going to fix you've also
got to figure out how to keep it from
happening again right and so once you've
identified your corrections a huge huge
piece of that is that you need to figure
out what defects did you find in your
data collection stage
so do you need to improve your
monitoring
are you collecting all of the things
that you need are you also logging it
did you figure out that you're actually
monitoring the things correctly but
you're not storing that data because
monitoring and logging go hand in hand
there is no point in having active
monitoring that you don't also save so
that you can do this kind of analysis
later likewise there's no point in
logging data that no one is ever looking
at so they are hand in hand and that's a
big piece of identifying the corrections
identifying what you are going to fix
all right so we've found our gaps in
monitoring we've found our gaps in
logging we figured out what other
corrections it is that we need to make
now what do we do now we've got to
implement the solution right now is the
implementation phase
so
implementation we have to implement not
just the short-term fix that we use to
solve the outage that we had but we also
have to implement all of the long-term
things right monitoring logging other
corrections software defects maybe we
have a change management problem
you have to implement all of those fixes
and you have to get them out there
because there's no point in doing the
work to just let it sit right if you
write up the rca and you don't implement
all of the changes that you need in
order to
make sure it doesn't happen again again
it's paperwork exercise not worth
identifying the time
and then the last step and this is the
one that is often the hardest for
everyone involved in any kind of a
customer impacting event is
communication
so i'm just going to put this up here as
comms
and i'm going to underline actually i'm
going to underline it twice
communication is so important because
once you have figured out what the
problem is you figured out how you're
going to fix it you figured out what
gaps and defects you have you've
implemented those gaps and defects you
have to keep your stakeholders apprised
of what is going on and it's hard for us
to admit that things went wrong it's
hard for us to admit that there were
failures that were our fault that we
have acknowledged and we're going to fix
and so if we think about a company
culture
columns around rcas are so important
because it is acknowledging to your
customers yes we're not perfect we made
a mistake or the vendors that we
selected had a problem or
really just about anything that could go
wrong will eventually go wrong but we
are reassuring you through our
communication in this rca process that
we know that things happen and we are
going to fix it and ensure that it never
happens again
this comms piece is the most important
part you can't just write up a two or
three sentence yes
something broke we've identified fixes
we've implemented them and we'll make
sure it doesn't happen again you need to
go one level further than that you have
to restore that trust and restore your
customers confidence in you
that you are acknowledging that you are
not perfect and you're going to fix
things so that they don't happen again
and then you've got to keep that
communication going once you've reached
this implementation phase and you've
actually got the problem rolled out
at that point
keep up with your customers if somebody
had a cie six months ago reach out to
them be sure that they're still okay be
sure that they've accepted the plan that
you gave them on how it's never going to
happen again and be sure that they're
okay with it and that it's solving their
needs
so thank you so much hopefully this was
helpful to you if you have any questions
or comments please feel free to share
them with us below if you enjoyed this
video and you would like to see more
like it in the future please do like the
video and subscribe to us so that we'll
know to keep creating for you